welcome and welcome back to another
coffee break here on my channel firm
learning
my name is heinrich and on my channel i
want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career
today's video is quite special we're
going to talk about a topic that i
haven't covered a lot yet on this
channel we're going to talk about
investment banking
and i invited a special guest through
this channel to help me cover this topic
it is afzai afzal is a former goldman
sachs consultant he will help you
understand what investment banking is
all about
we will discuss the key divisions in
investment banking and also some tips
what you can do to get into a job
like goldman sachs or other budget
bracket banks this way
after there's a youtube channel called
afsalhusain i will link it below in the
video description he makes lots of great
videos on investment banking and related
topics i can really recommend you to
check it out
but now without further ado let's jump
in let's learn what working at
investment banks like goldman sachs
looks like and what you can do to get
such a job this way
hey thank you for tuning in today my
name is afsal hussein
and i run a youtube channel called afzal
hussein
heinrich will link it in the video
description below long story short i
graduated six seven years ago now i went
to a mid-tier university queen mary in
london and i studied economics and
finance
my goal at uni was to do as many spring
weeks and internships as possible got my
internship at goldman sachs within their
asset management business i did that for
10 weeks and converted that into a
full-time offer after i graduated i
joined goldman's full-time in the asset
management business as a salesperson
and i did that for a few years until i
left to pursue entrepreneurship
full-time but i don't want to waste too
much time i want to get straight to
the value that i can add for you and
what i want to do in this video is
explain to you a bit about the
investment banking division at an
investment bank the sales and trading
division at an investment bank and
asset management and private banking
because these are the four
or four of the front office divisions at
an investment bank so you've got the
front office
which are revenue generating higher
salaries higher bonuses
client facing and then you've got the
back office things like human resources
finance operations so on and so forth
why i want to focus on the front office
areas for you today is because i get a
lot of management consultants a lot of
consulting interns graduates etc who
reach out to me
and ask me how can they break into
investment banking or how can they break
into asset management and so i'll touch
on all of these and then i'll touch on
some of the similarities in the skill
sets that you guys will have as
individuals with a consulting background
or experience in the world of consulting
and then i'll touch on some of the
differences between consulting and
working for an investment bank so that
you
can kind of focus on the key gaps that
you need to fill
if you're ever interested in breaking in
without any further ado let's get
straight into it the investment banking
division is basically corporate advisory
what individuals do in the investment
banking division is help companies raise
money
whether it's through equity issuing
equity or issuing debt
they help companies restructure their
business so they look at the company's
equity to debt ratio and assess
if a company can be organized in a
better way in order to
function more efficiently and increase
shareholder value
and they help companies merge or take
over so corporate advisory in essence
focuses on all of these areas when you
go into the investment banking division
as a junior
you are going to be heavily focused on
building models financial models and
valuation models on excel and working on
presentation skills on
microsoft powerpoint these are the two
tools that you're going to be using
for the most part in your first few
years in the investment banking division
and so naturally you bring a lot of that
over from management consulting
to investment banking because you do a
lot of that in the world of consulting
anyways the hours in the investment
banking division
are the longest in the industry you
would get in at like 9 a.m
and then you would leave in your first
few years midnight 1am 2am it's very
very long but as a result you get
compensated with large bonuses
at the end of the year and so if that's
something you're interested in it's
something worth looking at i've done
quite a few videos on the work life
balance salaries all of that those on my
channel you can check those out in your
spare time
then we've got the sales and trading
division this is the
market aspect or area of the investment
bank this is where you see traders on
the trading floor
glued into the financial markets they
are basically creating markets for
clients who want to buy or sell
financial securities and connecting them
with other clients
or individuals who want to buy and sell
financial securities the traders are on
the trading floor their sales people on
the trading floor
there's researchers on the trading floor
all of these people are coming up with
ideas
executing ideas in order to make a small
commission
of the large sums of money that the
clients are trading so
if you're interested in getting stuck
into the financial markets whether that
be
as a salesperson or a trader then this
might be something that you're
interested in typically you would get in
really early before the markets open so
six or seven am and then you would leave
at like five six seven pm and then
you've got
asset management and private banking
these areas basically
manage money over a long-term horizon
for their clients the key difference is
in private banking or private wealth
management
your clients are high net worth
individuals so rich people celebrities
footballers etc
and then in asset management your
clients are government organizations
local authorities
insurance companies pension schemes
sovereign wealth funds etc etc so
large corporations versus individuals
and family offices in asset management
and private banking you can be a
salesperson where you're managing client
relationships or you can be a product
person an investment professional
getting the money in and investing it
into the financial markets there are a
lot of people who come from management
consulting that break into asset
management or investment banking as
salespeople for example because they
have those
qualities that allow them to build
client relationships they have
interpersonal skills they're good
communicators they're good team workers
so on and so forth
key skills that are very similar
powerpoint presentation you use
a lot in consulting you use a lot in
banking why because
a lot of the work that a bank does or a
consulting firm does is pitch to clients
on powerpoint if you are
very good at microsoft powerpoint you
will be able to work faster more
efficiently
and just impress your seniors a lot
easier and so that's one key similarity
between the two industries another one
is excel
i'm not too sure how much you guys use
excel in management consulting i'm sure
you use it quite a bit but it's heavily
used
in investment banking division and on
the trading floor and so if you are good
on excel then that would be a bonus in
both worlds you
go and manage client relationships you
are pitching your ideas and solutions to
the clients
and you're trying to help them right and
then in the process you take a fee
for that service however if you want to
move from management consulting to
investment banking specifically it's
important to understand that in
investment banking you need a good
understanding
of accounting principles you need to be
able to
look into the inner workings of a
company by reading its financial
statements
and have an understanding of what it all
means that's what the investment bank
does
it takes all of that information puts it
into the excel models and then it
predicts or estimates the future
performance of that company in different
scenarios in management consulting i'm
not sure how much of that you do but if
you're considering breaking into banking
it's always good to have
some background knowledge in accounting
principles and financial statement
analysis if you want to make the
transition from management consulting to
banking
whether it's in asset management sales
and trading private banking or the
investment banking division
my advice to you three quick tips make
sure your cover letter is strong make
sure your cv is strong make sure you
network
talk to people in these industries
whether it's through linkedin or simply
whatever it is make sure you talk to
them
network ask them questions because
you'll be surprised how much you can
learn from connecting with people in the
industry they will help you get further
than just trying to make the transition
on your own without reaching out to
people or connecting with people
if you made it this far in the video
thank you so much if you want to find
out a bit more about me
or watch more of my videos i do videos
on banking finance careers
and general productivity lifestyle so
head over to my channel
heinrich will link it in the video
description below whatever stage you're
at
in your career whether you're not in
university yet whether you're in uni or
if you're a graduate good luck with your
journey persistence is key
stay inspired stay ambitious and yeah
thank you for watching this video thank
you so hope you found this video
insightful if you have any questions
just feel free to leave a comment below
in the comment section and i'm sure that
afzal is going to regularly look into
your comments and also answer all your
questions in addition as you know
every comment that you write really
helps me with the youtube algorithm so
every single comment is much appreciated
similar to that if you took any value
out of this video at all please hit the
like button for the youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel to
stay up to date on all my content to see
even more from me follow me on instagram
my handle is firm learning i also have a
mailing list there is a sign up link to
that in the video description below i
now want to say thank you to all the
members of firm learning
every member makes a significant
contribution to the work to the course
of this channel so your support is very
much appreciated and if you are thinking
about becoming a member as well just hit
the join button next to the subscribe
button to learn what it's all about and
yes you have
access to some member only perks if you
join as a member thank you to everybody
who watched until the end i release new
videos every single saturday so looking
forward to next week's video and until
then enjoy the weekend
bye bye guys